[Music]
how's it going Devin here again with
country guar
online.com hope you all are having a
great week got an awesome lesson today
for y'all we are going to continue on
with this lesson series that we've been
working on here at country guitar online
learning how to play really nice rhythm
guitar Phil riffs and if you're just now
joining us for this series uh when I say
fill riff I'm talking about a short riff
that you can add into your cord
progressions as kind of like a little
fill makes your rhythm guitar sound a
little fancier so here's an example of
what we've been looking at so far in the
series
[Music]
you know tons of stuff like that and
we've been focusing
on trying to figure out how to create
that country in bluegrass sound and I've
been showing you a bunch of different
scales and been showing you how to use
those scales to create that country
sound that Bluegrass sound so um prior
lessons in the series we really focused
hard on the key of G fifth position
scales right here
and we learn some cool fills just like
what I played right there um so if you
haven't seen the previous lessons in the
series definitely check those out
awesome stuff and you can get caught up
to where we're at
today now in this lesson what we're
going to do is we're going to travel up
the neck a bit and we're going to learn
four more scales but we're going to be
learning them in the next scale position
up the neck in the key of G and that's
going to be the first position key of G
scales cuz if you remember there's five
positions that span the
neck key of G the fifth position is
right there and then after that it wraps
around goes to the first position second
third fourth so on so we're going be
checking out the first position today
learning some nice country and Bluegrass
sounding fil
riffs a little bit farther up the neck
so anyways let's get to it let's start
playing through the four scales we're
going to learn today and after we play
through the scales I'm going to show you
all some awesome fill riffs that have
that really nice country and Bluegrass
sound so let's start checking out those
scales with the
charts right here in this first position
key of G I use four main scales to
create this country and Bluegrass sound
first scale that I use is the the major
pentatonic scale and it we're going to
learn the exact same four scales that we
learned in the fifth position earlier in
this series except now we're just going
to learn them in the first position same
scale types but just different
location so here we go let's play
through this pentatonic scale major
pentatonic scale
[Music]
really basic scale that one's used in a
bunch of different genres but very
important to Country and bluegrass music
playing these
fills you can learn all these scales we
got charts to all these on the on the uh
scale charts tab on this lesson post so
if you want to just head over there if
you're ready to to look at the charts
and start memorizing these scales you
can do that too but just want to play
through them so you can hear them real
quick second scale that I use is the
major
scale the complete major scale so it's
pretty much the same scale as this major
pentatonic scale that we just learned
just adding a couple extra notes per
octave to get to that full major scale
so here is the complete major scale
[Music]
kind of busher it at the end um but you
get the
[Music]
idea major scale that one's also very
very
important third scale we got is the
minor pentatonic scale
[Music]
there's a trick
to this scale position right here the
first position minor pentatonic
scale so remember that shape that we
learned um in the in the fifth position
the G major pentatonic scale this one
[Music]
that shape right there we learned
earlier in the series that's the exact
same shape as the one we're learning now
the minor pentatonic scale first
position it's kind of weird how it works
and some of youall may already know this
but those of youall that don't know this
this is going to be really helpful so
that major pentatonic scale that I just
played right there
if you take that shape and you shift it
up three Frets so we'll go to the first
fret second fret third fret right
there and start the scale with the root
note and play that same shape now at a
different
[Music]
location that's the minor pentatonic
scale now but the first position that's
how these scales work uh you can take
the major pentatonic scale whatever key
you're playing you can shift it up three
Frets and this is same case for all five
scale positions take that major
pentatonic scale shift it up one two
three play the same shape and now it's
the minor pentatonic scale it's pretty
amazing how the guitars tuned tune like
that it actually works
out but it always sounds great in
country bluegrass music when you can
switch back and forth between the major
pentatonic scale and the minor
pentatonic scale and this is a real easy
way to do that is just shift at three
Frets and boom there you are playing the
same scale shape but it's got a slightly
different sound to it a little little
Bluer sound when you switch up to the
that minor pentatonic
[Music]
scale U if that doesn't make sense you
drop a comment in the comment box below
this video answer any questions y'all
got on that
that's the minor pentatonic scale right
there then the fourth scale that I use
is the blue scale and remember the blue
scale it's basically the same scale as
the minor pentatonic scale except we're
just adding in one note extra per octave
so it's minor pentonic scale plus that
note right there on the first octave
up and then there's the next blues
[Music]
note got a very bluesy
sound so the blue scale is probably my
favorite out of all these scale
shapes I just think it's so useful for
country and
Bluegrass and I'm a big fan of playing
Blues too so
[Music]
um
anyways you take a step back and you
look at all four of those scales at the
end of the day you basically just got
two scales that you need to learn you
got the major
scale and the blue scale because the
major scale and the major pentatonic
scale so similar you know the major
scale just has some extra notes but it
it still has all the notes of the the
pentaton scale and then you got the the
blue scale blue scale basically is the
minor pentatonic scale same scale just
some extra notes so blue scale and the
major scale I would really focus on
learning those two scales right here in
the
uh in the the first position key of G
really hard to talk and and play at the
same time but uh anyways those are the
scales so let's figure out how to use
them let's start turning these scales
into some cool sounding country and
Bluegrass Phil Rifts
[Music]